univers post apocalyptique où décalé
avec des gobelins âgé de tout juste six
mois l'entreprise exode games composé de
trois salariés développe des jeux de
société dans ses bureaux
particularité ils sont installés au sein
de stopper works un espace de coworking
à montigny le bretonneux pour des jeunes
sociétés on nous avons des services de
équivalent des grands comme un standard
téléphonique une domiciliation du
courrier et on a la possibilité surtout
avec stephen ward de s'étendre
on a commencé on avait que deux bureaux
aujourd'hui on en a trois donc c'est
petit à petit on pourra s'étendre si on
veut prendre plus de bureau plus espace
les plateaux de jeux cartes et figurines
sont conçus et fabriqués sur place de
référence seront bientôt disponibles
on pourra trouver des gobeline à d'un
jeu destiné à un public familial en
septembre prochain en magasins dès le
mois d'octobre
after ziad un jeu experts fera l'objet
d'une campagne de financement
participatif des gobelins en boutique
on compte le faire à 30 euros tandis que
l'acteur diène étant donné qu'on passe
par la plateforme de financement
participatif kickstarter les bikers ils
pourront eux-mêmes jauger ce qu'ils
donneront s'ils veulent tout simplement
soutenir le projet à hauteur de 10 euros
20 euros ou si ils veulent soutenir le
projet en plus recevoir le produit donc
là faudra
faudra compter sur une centaine d'euros
objectif pour la jeune société au cours
des trois prochaines années
proposer encore plus de références et
tripler son chiffre d'affaires